the wind family sat down for Sunday
lunch attended today by a priest the son
wind in lung absent they believed he was
among the 39 people found dead in the
trailer as more families speak two
things are becoming clearer their routes
into the UK and their reasons for going
there
[Music]
we know that he does no longer have a
boot camp many Vietnamese have left here
for the wealth of Europe then ending our
part of its informal economy yawning
down the duty of denial of Americans
anymore but opportunities abroad or a
path to learn all of the families we've
spoken to you have different stories but
a common thread starts to emerge people
here are poor sometimes in debt but it's
more that they're sold a dream of the UK
a dream that do anything to make happen
other families like boy thenahms
have less to go on why not come did say
gonna be okay lousy and up near there
now they haven't heard from her since
October 21st when she said she was in
Germany two days before the lorry was
discovered calm down lady
something came up doing choir midnight
despite that foreboding procedure they
have not given up say mom like I'm gone
calm ma'am don't eat you insane day
welcome other families have the same
hope for those who left town Cheshire
Sky News neon